[Musique]
j'ai une affaire vous proposer un
m'intéresse pas de quoi s'agit-il d'un
pistolet avant de voir voilà c'est un
pistolet qui appartenait au frère de
buffalo bills à buffalo bill avait un
frère ça j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
son frère d'un pistolet comme un
rendez-vous 150 francs mais que voulez
vous que je fasse deux pistolets merci
j'en ai déjà vu
non je vous dis ça parce que souvent
fait les lampes de chèques des objets
qui ne sont pas des lampes de chevet que
voulez-vous dire un homme jeune ami qui
chez lui a transformé sa trompette en
lampe de chevet alors que tu vas jouer
de la trompette il soudain sa lampe de
chevet non je vous de la contrebasse pas
pourquoi tu une trempette à ce qu'une
controverse est trop grand pour faire un
homme de cheval alors on est moins de
trompette confère une âme de chemin et
non pour jouer de la trompette mais j'ai
pas tombé davantage en pistolet je n'ai
quand même pas souvenir d'un pistolet
non mais voyant faire une lampe de
chevet pourquoi faire jouer de la
trompette ce soir dans votre lit vous
êtes fous ma femme kate jane l'insomnie
c'est parce qu'il y avait trop de café
sachets mois une fois plus de café
depuis quand depuis qu'on a fait le
nombre de chèques le moulin à café
oui il s'agit bien que vous avez une
norme de je n'ai pas de pistolet taser
alors acheté mon bissonnette mais j'vous
dis que ça m'intéresse pas non ça vous
intéresse pas parce que vous n'avez pas
besoin d'un pistolet mais je vous
appelle vous n'êtes pas obligé de vous
en servir comme d'un pistolet que voulez
vous en fasse une poignée de porte
persie a déjà une non je vous dis ça
parce que souvent elle est priée de
contacter celui qui le porte
que voulez-vous dire ah non j'ai un ami
qui séduit remplacer swinford par des
bananes et bananes des bananes alors que
tu veux manger des bananes il épluché
poignées de porte un nom à son pas vu
les poignées de portes dont les bananes
pas quand elles sont mûres la rachète
des vertes et les autres en fait il y
les manches
ouais ben moi j'aime pas les bananes
alors c'est moi mon pistolet à eau mais
enfin pourquoi tenez vous absolument à
me vendre ce pistolet si j'ai besoin
d'argent
c'est ça le fallait dire tout de suite
comme l'acheter donc bon ben je vais je
trouver de l'argent mois dans une banque
qui ne s'est pas de comptes patanock
bonjour
jamais pourtant attaqué un passant a
witch ou lima donnez-moi 153 mais qu'est
ce qui vous prend rendez-vous des mois
150 francs je peux vous donner 150
transiger les demandeurs alors oui c'est
une main et des nomades 75 francs voilà
merci
[Musique]